[Applause] Mandell elmar watches him borling one
timer score the power play
it's G [Applause] [Music]
forset first of the air for the big defenseman
good Puck Movement by the Panthers regain
control off of their first shot get back look
at londelle highing out in front nothing there
put it back to the point traffic in front
cousins was there that shot's going over
100 milph folks and it whistles right by
on the glove hand Bing's first point first
goal of the season and oh is it a big one a
minute 19 after Seattle took a two- nothing
lead the Panthers cash it in and get the crowd
into the game well if the Panthers can continue
to create that speed that they're trying to
achieve and going to the front of the net and
battling for loose pucks the Kraken will take
some penalties and the Panthers they'd love
to have a few more power play opportunities
in this second period Mondell wins the face
off kulakov shoots def fed score it's in and the
Panthers have tied it with a couple of quick ones
well that didn't take very long oh Matthew
K check I think he might be the last one
to touch this all off the draw lundell
wins it shot towards the front of the
goal and it goes off the Stick of kachuck
and just butterflies into the back of the
net there's the redirection from kachuk
it might have hit lundell but Nei way
way the Panthers have tied it up quickly
yeah looks like a Chuck from kulakov and
Mika wow 11 seconds two goals and from
2 down to even for the Panthers time
to go 734 second period what a response by
Florida we've seen him do it so many times
over the last few seasons you just can never
count them out and they played a pretty good
period just Seattle got that one goal in
their one shot well and it starts for the
Panthers winning those draws whether they're
on the power play or they five on five goal no